JAREK WILKIEWICZ:
Hello, everyone.
My name is Jarek Wilkiewicz.
Welcome to YouTube
Developers Live.
We have an exciting show
for you today.
In the studio, we have
Shawn Simister.
How are you, Shawn?
SHAWN SIMISTER: Hi.
I'm great.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Shawn works on
Freebase and Freebase API.
We will tell you more about what
Freebase has to do with
YouTube Knowledge Graph,
semantic search, a lot of
interesting new concepts.
And then we also have
Greg Schechter.
How are you doing, Greg?
GREG SCHECHTER: I'm
doing very well.
How are you?
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Good.
Long time, no see.
GREG SCHECHTER: Ah, yeah.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: So first of
all, I would like to welcome
Greg to our team.
Greg has recently switched from
full-time engineering on
YouTube to full-time Developer
Relations.
GREG SCHECHTER: I'm pretty
excited for it.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: If you guys
had watched the previous
appearance by Greg about HTML5,
I think he liked it a
little bit too much.
He decided to make this
a full-time job.
Welcome.
How has your first couple of
weeks been going so far?
GREG SCHECHTER: They've
been very busy.
There's a lot to learn
and a lot to do.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Yeah?
Is it an adjustment?
Do you feel like it is very
different from what you're
doing before?
Is it--
GREG SCHECHTER: I think it's
a good transition.
I'm focusing a lot more on
reaching out to the developer
community, and that's a lot
of fun, so it's good.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Well, very
happy to have you, and welcome
to the team.
So let's talk a little
bit about you, Shawn.
You've been at Google
for how long?
SHAWN SIMISTER: I've been
at Google now for
a year and a half.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: OK, and you
have been involved in the
Freebase community for much
longer than that, right?
SHAWN SIMISTER: Yeah,
for five years now.
I was a member of the Freebase
community for three years
before coming here, so a lot of
experience in the Freebase
community before I came.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: So what
got you into Freebase?
SHAWN SIMISTER: I was very
interested in Wikipedia, and
in open data, and in a lot
of those different areas.
And when Freebase came out, it
was the first one that had a
really easy-to-use API for
accessing that sort of
structured data.
So that was something that
I really appreciated.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: So maybe
we should talk about what
Freebase is.
What is it?
SHAWN SIMISTER: Yeah,
absolutely.
So Freebase is an open
Knowledge Graph with
information of over 23
million entities.
So these are real-world
entities--
people places, things.
And like I said, there's an API
for that, so developers
can tap into that
knowledge base.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: So are
entities represented, or are
the relationships represented
as well
between these entities?
SHAWN SIMISTER: Yeah, so it's
not just the entities, but
also the relationships
between them.
So we have information about
people, but we also have
information about the
relationships between those
people, whether they're married
or whether they work
together, that sort of thing.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: So not only
the hierarchy of the objects
that are in the database,
but also how
they are linked together.
SHAWN SIMISTER: Exactly.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: So that kind
of reminds me of that
Knowledge Graph, something
that I
have heard about recently.
Is there a relationship between
the Knowledge Graph
and Freebase?
SHAWN SIMISTER: So absolutely.
So Freebase is one of the
sources that Google uses to
build its Knowledge Graph.
And I think we have a video here
to explain a little bit
more about the Knowledge
Graph.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: OK, let's
take a look at the video.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-Wouldn't it be amazing if
Google could understand that
the words that you use when
you're doing a search, well,
they aren't just words.
They refer to real things
in the world.
That a building is a building,
and an animal is an animal,
and that they're not just random
strings of characters.
If we can understand that those
words are talking about
those real-world things, then
we can do a better job of
getting you just the content
that you want off the web.
-The way Google is trying to
build information about
real-world connections is by
building a Knowledge Graph.
The Knowledge Graph is about
collecting information about
objects in the real world.
The object could be a person,
could be a book, could be a
movie, and many other
types of things.
For example, for a famous
person, we collect relevant
data about them, such as
their date of birth or
how tall they are.
We can also connect that person
to closely-related
objects in the Knowledge
Graph.
-Let's say you're interested
in Renaissance painters, or
how about how many women have
won the Nobel Prize.
By understanding the
relationships between things,
be it between painters in the
Renaissance or women and the
Nobel Prize, Google can do a
better job of understanding
what it is exactly you're
searching for.
-One of the first features we
are going to introduce, which
applies the Knowledge
Graph, is a panel
next to the web results.
-When you have a question to
answer, others may have come
to Google already to search
for the same thing.
Google can jump-start your
research process by combining
the information that others
found useful with the
information in the
Knowledge Graph.
-All of the collective human
wisdom that comes through our
search engine, what people are
searching for, tells us what
are the interesting things
to put in our database.
-Take Leonardo da Vinci.
Let's say you wanted to learn
about the most important
Renaissance painters.
You might search for Leonardo
da Vinci because he is the
only Renaissance painter
you know about.
Now you'll see information right
in the search results
that helps you explore
the broader topic
of Renaissance painters.
You'll see some of the most
famous paintings from that
era, like "The Mona Lisa," and
discover other painters of
that time, like Michelangelo
and Raphael.
-We're in the early phases
of moving from being an
information engine to becoming
a knowledge engine, and these
enhancements are one step
in that direction.
-As we grow the Knowledge Graph
and make it larger and
richer, we're really excited
about the opportunity we have
to understand more of the users'
queries, to understand
more about the information
that's out there on the web,
and intelligently connect
the two to each other.
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Great.
So it looks like Search already
uses that information.
And thinking about Freebase, I
was actually an artificial
intelligence major in college,
and I remember learning about
the project to replicate common
sense called Cyc.
So is that the goal
of Freebase?
What was the actual original
goal, and where is it going?
SHAWN SIMISTER: So Freebase
and Cyc are both knowledge
bases about real-world things.
They have a couple differences,
though.
Freebase is aiming to make it
easy for developers to access
these facts about real
world things.
Whereas Cyc is aiming to model
common-sense knowledge about
the world and let AI researchers
and developers
program with that sort of
intuitive real-world knowledge.
So it's a little bit
different in scope.
Freebase is also built
up by an open
community like I said before.
So anyone can contribute.
Cyc was designed by Cycorp, and
they've designed most of
the schema and the objects
on their database.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: I see.
So it sounds like Freebase has
the objects entities, the
relationships, where Cyc is also
focused on the assertions
based on the knowledge
that they have
accumulated in their system.
SHAWN SIMISTER: Yeah, there's
a lot more rules in Cyc.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ:
I see, I see.
Cool.
GREG SCHECHTER: So you mentioned
that Freebase is an
open community and stuff and
people can contribute.
What does that involve?
How are they contributing
to it?
SHAWN SIMISTER: So
it's very easy.
It's a lot like the Wikipedia
model where anyone can jump in
and contribute as little as one
factor, as much as a whole
domain of facts with all the
schema and everything.
So anyone with a Google account
can register, can log
into Freebase.
They can go to any topic, any
one of the 23 million topics
in Freebase.
They can add facts.
They can change facts.
It's like a Wiki so you can see
a history of which facts
have been changed.
And then they can build
their own schema.
And there's a way that those
schemas can get promoted so
that they become common schema
that everyone uses.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Nice.
And you were talking
about the schema
relationships' entities.
Now this is an API show, so is
there an API that I can use?
And then additionally, I heard
that you can actually get
access to the real data, so can
you tell us a little bit
more about that?
SHAWN SIMISTER: Absolutely.
So Freebase is a big
graph database.
Everything is stored
in the graph.
So you can use our APIs to query
all of those things--
the schema, the topics, even
the users, and all
that sort of stuff.
So we have free APIs
that anyone can use
to query the data.
And we also, like you said, we
have a complete data dump.
So you can download every single
fact in Freebase onto
your own computer, do whatever
you like with it.
It's a Creative Commons
attribution license.
So as long as you give us a
little credit, you can do
anything you want with
all this data.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Neat, neat.
So can you show us couple
of examples of how
you work with it?
Let's see if we can switch
to your laptop.
SHAWN SIMISTER: Is that
showing up there?
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: We good?
SHAWN SIMISTER: So this is one
example of using Freebase data
to organize a lot of content
around topics.
And so this is a start-up
called Link TV.
And they're doing news around
real-world topics, and they've
used Freebase to
organize that.
So you can see there's a lot
of news about Lebanon and
Syria right now.
And if you click on Lebanon,
that's going to take you to a
topic page about Lebanon.
And you can see they've pulled
in some data here from
Freebase, a description, an
image, that sort of thing.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Is the image
stored by Freebase as well?
SHAWN SIMISTER: Yes,
it is, yeah.
And then they're able to show
relevant videos around that
similar to I think what
we're going to be
talking about today.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Great.
And then Developer view.
This is a very nice presentation
of the data.
Can you show us, how
does a developer
interact with Freebase?
SHAWN SIMISTER: So there's a
number of different ways.
We have Search API, which lets
you take keywords and enter
those keywords into the Search
API, and get back a ranked
list of results.
So topics that we think closely
match the keywords
that you gave us.
Then we have the Topic API,
which is kind of the other
side of the Search API, which is
you give us a Freebase ID.
So those ranked list of search
results before each one will
have a topic ID.
But once you have the topic ID,
you can pass that into the
Freebase API, and we'll give
you back every fact that we
know about that topic.
And that's in real time.
So if you go and edit Freebase,
the Topic API is
updated automatically.
And then the last API that we
have is called the MQL--
"Mickle"--
Read API.
And that let's--
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Why
is it called MQL?
SHAWN SIMISTER: That's the
Metaweb Query Language.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: All right,
Metaweb was the company that
Google acquired--
SHAWN SIMISTER: Yeah,
the original.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: --when
they started Freebase.
SHAWN SIMISTER: Yes.
And so The MQL Query API lets
you write more complicated
structured queries.
So you can ask it things like,
give me a list of all the
actresses who've won awards for
films which were adapted
from books.
And normally in a relational
databases, that
would be a lot of joins.
But in a graph database, you're
just kind of hopping
through all these
relationships.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Hence
the Knowledge Graph.
SHAWN SIMISTER: Yeah, exactly.
So we actually have this Query
Editor here, which lets you
write those queries in the
MQL query language.
So you can see here, the query
is just nested JSON objects,
and you're specifying
types and properties
using Freebase schema.
And all the null values that I
have here are things that we
want to get back from the API.
So it's going to fill in--
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: So it's like
a template-based approach?
SHAWN SIMISTER: Exactly.
It's a template-based
query language.
So it's a little bit different
if you're used to SQL-type
query languages.
But it's very easy to learn.
It's just plugging in all
the Freebase schema.
And then I'm going
to click Run.
You get back this structured
list of results.
You can see everywhere where I
had null, it's been filled in
with values.
So you can see Dakota Fanning
won an award for "War of the
Worlds," which was a movie which
was based on a book.
And so all this information is
available as JSON in your
application.
You can parse that out, do
whatever you like with it.
And you can actually
just click up here.
There's a link to
the MQL Read.
And this is the actual raw API
request that you need to do to
get that in there.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: So
it's a RESTful API.
You can pick JSON.
And then can you use the Google
APIs to interact with
that as well?
SHAWN SIMISTER: Yes.
So the new Freebase APIs are all
compatible with the Google
API clients.
So you can use those clients
to parse this.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: So if I go to
the Developer console and
select Services, you will
actually see Freebase?
SHAWN SIMISTER: You'll
see Freebase.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: --in
the listing.
SHAWN SIMISTER: Exactly.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: OK.
Great.
And right now it's open.
Anybody can use it.
Just add it to your
application.
SHAWN SIMISTER: Yeah, it's
completely free.
There's a quota of I believe
10,000 requests you can make
in a day, so pretty generous.
And if you have needs where you
need to do more than that,
you can talk to us as well
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: OK, cool.
I know I Greg has been
hacking actually with
Freebase API as well.
And this is a YouTube
API show.
So Greg, tell us a little more
about YouTube API, how that
relates to Freebase, maybe
show us the example.
I know Jeff, who is out on
vacation, actually started
working on this project
a few weeks back.
So this is the first
public preview of
Jeff was able to achieve.
But I know you've been looking
into it, so tell us
a little bit more.
GREG SCHECHTER: Yeah, so I'm
going to pull up this Topic
Explorer is what we call it.
It's basically just a way
to sort of browse
the Freebase stuff.
And so if we pull it up
on the computer here.
I can log into it with
my personal account.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: So what
you're doing is
basically Auth flow.
GREG SCHECHTER: And so this is
using the Google standard
authorization client libraries
in JavaScript.
And then it's going to fetch
some information about me.
It's got my username there.
And now it shows me all this
stuff, all these tags that
sort of relate to me.
And I really like of the first
one happens to be about cats,
because I guess--
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Shocker.
GREG SCHECHTER: --I like
my cat videos a lot.
SHAWN SIMISTER: Now
are those YouTube
tags or Freebase topics?
GREG SCHECHTER: So these are
Freebase topics that I guess
are being pulled from
information that it knows
about me from my YouTube
habits--
what I like, what I watch,
and things like that.
So clearly I pay attention to
cat videos and HTML5 stuff,
and it looks like I watch
CollegeHumor and
other things like that.
So if I do a simple search,
I do like cats so
I'll keep it that.
Now it pulls in a bunch
of Freebase topics.
And so I can see like, well,
there's the organism.
There's things like there's a
football team here, cat eyes
as an invention.
There's all sorts of
different things.
So I'll pick one of these.
I'll just go with
the feral cat.
And when I click that, it goes
and fetches a bunch of
different YouTube entities.
So we have channels.
So there's one channel that's
about feral cats.
So we have a lot of
different videos.
And then from here, I can do
things like I can play a video
by just clicking on it.
Oh, well, this one's doesn't
happen to be available.
Let's see if this
other one is.
Good.
So it's just playing a video
from "The Stray Cats," which
happens to be a music group.
And you know what?
I like this video, so
I can Like it here.
And so this is a very simple
demo that just goes through
and uses a lot of these APIs.
So I'm going to dive
into the code.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: So before you
go there, just to recap.
So the features that this
application uses are Universal
Search, right?
Because when you typed in
"cats," we got not only videos
but also channels.
So this is something
new in API v3.
And also, the actual search
is no longer a
keyword search, right?
I think what is happening
under the hood is we're
actually looking for a topic.
GREG SCHECHTER: Yes.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: And then based
on the topic, we do the
lookup for YouTube videos or
playlists or channels that
relate to that specific
topic, right?
So this is kind of the linkage
between the part that Shawn
was talking about and what
the API v3 provides.
So for those of you that are
watching, this is kind of the
major difference between what
you could do in API v2, where
you could do a keyword search,
you could do a string search,
and it was all good.
But this is a little more
powerful because you can
actually search for concepts
that have semantic meaning.
And then you look at these
concepts in Freebase, and then
you query using the topic ID
that Shawn was describing.
And then I think Greg is going
to show us exactly how that's
done in the code.
GREG SCHECHTER: So what I did
is I took just pieces of the
code that I thought were
important for the API.
So the first thing I have here
is just a bunch of constants
that we laid out, and I'm going
to highlight the ones
that I think are important.
So the top two there, that's
for just doing Google
JavaScript client requests, and
that's what we're going to
use to hit a lot of
our YouTube calls.
And at the bottom of the
highlighted portion, you can
see the service and
the version.
The service is YouTube and the
version v3/ And then I also
have the Freebase URL in there,
and that's what we're
going to do to gather all the
topics when we have a query.
So the first thing that
we did in that demo,
we did a topic search.
I put in a query.
I put in cats, and I got back
a bunch of different topics.
So the code to do that
looks like this.
And really, the part that does
the request is right here.
It's a simple JSONP request,
and this is using the
AngularJS JavaScript library
for this request here.
So if you guys aren't familiar
with it, look it up.
But it's just a simple JSONP
request, and we put in our
query, which was cats, with
our API key and a
couple other things.
And so if I come to this page,
you can see that request is
going to go to a URL that's
at the bottom there.
And really it's just that URL
that I had in the constants,
plus our query for cats.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: So this
is the Freebase API--
GREG SCHECHTER: This is
the Freebase API.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ:
--invocation.
SHAWN SIMISTER: This is the
Search API that I was talking
about earlier--
GREG SCHECHTER: Exactly.
SHAWN SIMISTER: --where
you take keywords
and get topics back.
GREG SCHECHTER: And the result
for that looks like what I
have here on screen.
And if I highlight the portion,
the cool part is the
results here.
And so I just pulled out the top
result, and it happens to
be when you search for cat, the
first thing is, of course,
you get a cat.
And that's an organism
classification.
And there's a couple other
things there, and it has a
score, an ID, and an MID.
And the MID is what we'll use
later when we're actually
going to do our YouTube
Topics Search.
So the next thing with YouTube,
for our v3 API, to do
our request, this is kind of
a bigger chunk of code.
But the things that are
important here, this top line
here, which is just creating the
path, which will take to
YouTube service, which is just
YouTube, and our API version,
which is v3, and it'll send this
to the Google API client
JavaScript library, with all
these different options that
we'll see when we're actually
making these calls.
So for the search one, for the
universal search like we're
talking, it's very simple.
It's just the service that we're
using a search, like I
mentioned, and the params, we
have the topic ID, which is
the MID from before.
And we want to get the snippet
back, which will provide us
with the details about
that video.
And we also have a query in
there that will sort of limit
it to the search term that
we're putting in.
And so the URL is at
the bottom again.
So now we have, with the Google
APIs, and the most
important things there are
having YouTube, v3, and
search, which is the service
that we're using.
And then it drops in the topic
ID from before and has that we
want our snippet with searching
for cats, and the
key that we were using before.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: So before we
move forward, one important
thing to note is that to use the
topic APIs, you actually
have to do the lookup for the
topic ID first, with the
Freebase API.
And then you turn around and
feed that into the YouTube
API, right?
The cat's term was not actually
used with the YouTube
API, but instead, it
was a topic ID
retrieved from Freebase.
GREG SCHECHTER: Right, so you
can certainly just use cats
with YouTube API.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Sure.
GREG SCHECHTER: But if you want
to get more specific, you
want to get your--
in this case looking for
specifically organism, then
yeah, you'd have to do the
Freebase search to get the
topic ID first.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: As opposed
to the band, like in the
example you were showing?
GREG SCHECHTER: Uh-huh.
And the response to that is
pretty hefty, but the
important part is the different
items that you get.
And so here, I just have
the first result again.
And we see that if you look at
from the items, you look at ID
and kind, you can see that it's
a YouTube video with the
video ideas.
And then the snippet portion
sort of gives you some more
details, and it tells you
the channel ID that it's
associated to, the title of it
--"Funny Cats in Water." Epic.
That sounds like a blast--
and it gives you descriptions
and thumbnails.
So it's pretty simple
to get all this.
So hopefully, you'll be able
to use these examples to do
your own requests.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Neat.
Thank you for walking
us through the demo.
GREG SCHECHTER: Oh,
no problem.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: It's
very, very exciting.
I think one of the things that
we also have as a part of the
YouTube API v3 that isn't
actually captured by the demo
is, given a video or channel,
you can actually determine
topics that are related
to that video.
So it's really the opposite.
What we were showing here is
search and then topics,
although under the hood,
I think the original--
I don't know for those of you
that were watching, how when
Greg logged in, he actually
got a bunch of topics.
So these were actually topics
determined based on his
YouTube activity.
The reason why that was possible
is because we went
through the authenticated
access with Auth.
By the way, Greg, was there
anything in the results that
surprised you?
About yourself?
GREG SCHECHTER: Yeah.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Cats, that
was not a shocker.
GREG SCHECHTER: Cats
I did see like--
I don't know.
I pull it up here now.
And before, there were a lot of
references to "The Muppets"
and Kermit the Frog, which
was a bit unusual.
Although I do--
I mean, I love "The Muppets."
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Well, the
machine thinks you like it so
it's got to be right.
GREG SCHECHTER: I definitely
love watching those videos.
I didn't expect it to be so
prominent when I did the
search, though.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Yeah, when I
actually ran this for myself,
I thought it was quite accurate,
the types of things
I typically watch on YouTube.
But yeah, so the point is that
you can also-- based on
channel and based on
video, you can
actually get the topics.
So there's a part of the API
response that includes the
Freebase topics.
Then you can actually pivot and
look up information about
these topics in Freebase and
maybe find related concepts,
and related videos,
and so forth.
So that's another part of
the API that we have.
The API is still just a tester,
but we will be making
some announcements, hopefully,
reasonably soon, around when
we will be able to make
that available to
the developer community.
But Topics is a key feature
of the API v3.
It's always Universal Search,
which I think is a very nice
feature of the features
that are new in v3.
Great.
So let's look in the Moderator
queue if we have any questions
from people who are watching.
There's one question that I
think is relevant about
YouTube and Google Developer
Relations--
hiring.
So Greg, are we hiring?
GREG SCHECHTER: Yes,
of course.
We're always looking
for more people.
So we got positions for what
I do, which is Developer of
Programs Engineer, and positions
for what you do,
which is Developer Advocate.
I don't think the differences
are all that great.
We still work with our developer
community a lot.
I'm still trying to figure out
exactly where the line is
drawn, too.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Yeah.
I think one of the differences
is, I think on the Developer
Advocate side, we probably have
to travel a little more
than the Developer Programs
Engineer.
Folks like you or Jeff who can
actually stay in the zone for
longer and produce some of these
wonderful code examples
that we were showing.
Great.
And then if you would like
to learn more about these
positions, they're on
developers.google.com/jobs.
I think these are all the
questions that are relevant
that we have in the Moderator.
So again, thank you
very much, Shawn.
We're really looking forward to
playing more with Freebase.
Greg, welcome.
GREG SCHECHTER: It's
good to be here.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Thanks for
co-hosting, co-starring today,
looking forward to working with
you and going forward.
And for those of you watching,
thank you very much.
Next week, we will have an
exciting show for you as
always Wednesday 10:00
AM, Pacific.
[MUSIC PLAYING]